Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
Skaffold, a tool to ease development against Kubernetes
clusters, something I'm sure we can all agree
that we need.
Now before we get started, there is just
a little bit of housekeeping. First, if you're
not already subscribed,
please do that now. Click the bell, and
you will get notifications for all new episodes
of Rawkode Live.
Also, if you're not watching live but you
have questions or wanna suggest new episodes, please
feel free to join in Discord. There's a
few hundreds of us in there now always
talking Kubernetes, cloud native, and technology in general.
Come and get involved.
Lastly, I wanna thank my employer, EquinixMetal.
They allow that we need the time and
resources to invest in the shows and produce
native layer materials so that we can all
learn together. If you wanna check out Equinix
Medal, feel free to give us a code,
Rawkode.
This will get you $200
of credit. You can spend that really, really
quickly in about fifty hours with our beefier
machines, or you can make it last almost
four hundred hours with the smaller machines. So
pick your poison, use it wisely.
Okay. Now today, we're taking a look at
Skaffold. And to do that, I am joined
by Vic Anglazes from the Google team and
Skaffold team. Hi there, Vic. How are you?
I'm doing great. Thanks for having me. My
pleasure. I'm very excited to try and make
everyone's Kubernetes life a little bit easier today.
Likewise. Let's make it happen.
Alright. Do you wanna just take a little
bit of time and tell us a little
bit about you, and then we'll talk about
Skaffold?
Yeah. So, yeah, my name is Vicky Glacias.
I'm currently product manager at Google working on
Skaffold and the rest of our container tools.
I've been at Google for five years now,
very much in the cloud native space. I've
worked on Helm and a bunch of other
tools in the in the ecosystem, and now
really focusing my efforts on making sure we
have good, clean developer experiences on top of
Kubernetes clusters as well as a way to
bridge that experience into the operator tooling that
we use.
Nice.
Well, that sounds awesome, and I'm looking forward
to seeing what Skaffold's gonna bring to the
table then.
I believe you've got a little bit of
slides, so I'm gonna, just get the screen
started. We'll drive straight into the slides, and
then we'll have a little bit of a
chat afterwards.
Perfect.
You are live and good to go.
Alright. So just wanted to kinda tee up
Skaffold, and then, David, you'll take us through
kind of the documentation and showing us a
little bit more of the nitty gritty of
what it is, but just wanted to make
sure we have a overview of what we're
talking about here. So Skaffold
is is the tool we'll be talking about
today. We'll go through a little overview,
look at briefly the config, and then some
use cases that we can have for this
tool.
So when you think about developing on top
of Kubernetes and being kind of having some
sort of parity with your, production clusters that
are gonna run Kubernetes,
you have to do a lot of tasks
in order to emulate that production environment, which
has a CICD,
process behind it. Right? You have to, on
your local machine, build a container,
test it somehow,
make sure you have the right tags to
be able to reference it, push it to
a registry if your cluster is remote,
put that reference to those images inside of
your Kubernetes manifest, deploy those manifests to the
cluster, and then port forward your your service
to your local host so you can access
it, look at your logs, and then you
have to do that all over again whenever
you make a change. Right? So that's a
lot of effort that you're putting in in
order to do that. And some of the
challenges there are not just that you have
a lot of steps, but you have various
tools. Right? You're using Docker to do part
of it. You're using maybe VIM or Versus
Code in order to edit files. You're using
cube control in order to apply manifest, and
and really just gets tedious
to do all these tasks as fast as
you want them to be. And so what
we really wanted to build was hot coker
loading for Kubernetes.
You update a file on your file system,
and that is automatically realized inside of your
Kubernetes cluster with little to no effort on
your part. And so that's why we've bar
created Skaffold.
And Skaffold is open source. You can find
it at the Google Container Tools slash Skaffold
repo on GitHub.
And it takes all of those commands that
I showed and all those processes and all
those tools and condenses it down to one
command, which is Skaffold dev. So Skaffold dev
is gonna automate that whole workflow of building,
tagging, pushing, rendering, deploying, updating your application inside
of your cluster, all with a declarative config
and with a very pluggable architecture so that
you can choose the tools underneath the hood.
For example, when you're managing manifest, you might
start out with raw manifest on disk. You
might then go to Helm because you see
a lot of values that you wanna template
up. And then from there, you might go
to customize or some other tool in order
to manage those manifests. And we wanna make
sure we support you along the way. And
at at in your workflow, all you have
to run is Skaffold dev. You don't have
to think about those underlying tools.
One thing I did wanna point out is,
the awesome team that we have behind Skaffold.
These folks are super passionate about container tools,
super passionate about making the best possible,
experience for our users and for our community.
Just wanna call out Nick, who's our TL,
Tajol, who you had on last week, who,
was talking about Canico. She's our engine manager.
We have Brian,
who's our Glue TL. He's able to understand
the entirety of the tool chains underneath the
hood of Skaffold, which includes build packs. She
includes the way we debug. All of those
pieces need to integrate well, and he's got
all of that stuff mapped in. We've got
Marlon who's working on a lot of our
usability and onboarding tooling, who
worked on some of our complex,
config management, which we'll show later, and then
Aaron who's just joining us, after returning to
to the Skaffold project.
So now that we've teed up, we've got
a a tool that helps us for development.
We've got an awesome team behind it. What
can you do with it? Right?
And there's really three categories that we think
about. We think about being able to do
can discontinuous development loop, right, being able to
quickly and easily get that hot code reloading
feel out of your Kubernetes
applications.
But, also, we wanna help you with your
continuous integration and GitOps journeys. Right? We wanna
make sure that you can reuse what you've
already configured in your dev loop for these
CI journeys and to get those manifest ready
for committing into your GitOps repo. The last
thing we're able to do is is help
you with your continuous delivery and make sure
that you deploy your manifest in the same
way that you did during development.
So what do you need to do in
order to get comfortable with Skaffold? First and
the most important part is probably getting your
config file. Right? And so our config file,
for those in the cloud native ecosystem,
probably looks very familiar. This is a Kubernetes
resource model config.
We have an API version kind and then
some config blocks under that. Right? So the
the config blocks look like
build,
test, deploy, render, things like that.
And, really, as you kind of build out
these configs, you see that you can swap
each of the tools in each of these
pieces, which makes it really nice for transitioning
between tools and not having to change the
way your developers develop. Right? It may be
that an operator wants to change out the
way they handle manifests. It may be that
developers
have changed the way they wanna build their
images.
With this abstraction that Skaffold provides, those teams
don't really have to coordinate those changes. They
can just coordinate them through the configuration files,
which is a really nice way to do
it.
I talked a little bit about the the
structure of the Skaffold YAML. You have your
API version kind, and then you talk about
your builds, how you're gonna get images, how
you're gonna test those images, and then how
you're gonna deploy those images. One last thing
that you can do is create profiles that
allow you to have kind of configurations
that are specific to a particular environment or
a particular use case.
Cool. So now you've got this configuration file.
Now you wanna iterate on your app.
Well, we take all of this flow that
I talked through earlier, and we turn it
into one command, and that's Skaffold dev. It's
gonna do all of these things, build, test,
tag, push, render, deploy,
forward, and update as you change files within
your IDE or within VAM or Emacs or
whatever you're using as your editor.
So then once you commit that file into
your repo and you wanna have
another teammate use that same config or you
wanna onboard
a new team member, all they have to
do is git clone your repo and run
Skaffold dev. And they've got your best practices
for development already on their machine without having
to do anything else. So that's a really
powerful tool, and we've seen a lot of
customers use this for their onboard.
So now you've gotten that iterative dev loop
going. What do you wanna do next? Well,
you wanna deploy to production or staging. Right?
And we can use Skaffold as a bridge
between that dev loop and the CICD pipeline.
And the way we're gonna do that, you
saw those blocks in the config file. Right?
You have the build and deploy block. Well,
we're gonna take this big pipeline that we
had and chunk it up a little bit
and run only individual pieces when we need
it. For example,
you might have just the left side of
this pipeline running in CI and the right
side running in c. So let's see how
that might look. So, for example, in CI,
you wanna build your images, tag them, and
push them. So you can take that same
configuration that's in your repo and run Skaffold
build, and it'll only do that chunk.
Right? Build, tag, and push your images. Another
important thing that it does is it takes
that
those images that it built and puts them
into a file called artifacts dot JSON, And
then you can use that in other pieces
of your CI system.
For example, when you wanna go to deploy,
you can pass that artifacts JSON to the
Skaffold deploy command, and Skaffold deploy will take
care of rendering, deploying, and forwarding your logs
for that that service. Right? So now we're
able to run individual commands to do just
pieces of this pipeline, but we're sharing the
same config between our development loop and our
CI process and our CE process.
You might also wanna do GitOps. Right?
So you can take the Skaffold render command,
which will not only build, tag, and push
your your images,
but it'll also take those references to those
images and put them into your Kubernetes manifest
and give you back raw YAML that then
you could apply into a cluster if you
wanted, or you could commit that directly into
a repo and have a GitOps operator like
Flux or something else pick that up and
push that up to to production or staging.
Finally,
the other part that we've added, very recently
is to take that manifest that's been put
out by Skaffold render and apply it into
the cluster while doing health checks for those
services and and deployments that have been put
out. Again, these are the same health checks
that we use during development, so you get
that unification between your dev loop and your
CICD pipeline.
The last thing that I'll mention is a
lot of iterating,
in the development loop is wanting to debug
something that's wrong in your app. And we
have Cloud Code, which is our Versus Code
and IntelliJ extensions,
which lets you have this hot code reloading
field through your IDE by just hitting your
run on Kubernetes button or f five,
or you can also have it connect directly
to those applications
via the debugging functionality.
So this is transparent to you as the
as the user. We connect to your app.
We put in the right debugging tools into
your pods
and then connect back the port onto your
local host so that you can hit a
breakpoint inside of Versus Code, and it'll hit
the breakpoint inside of your your Kubernetes application
running in your cluster. So super powerful stuff.
Definitely check out Cloud Code as kind of
an interface around Skaffold that can make it
easier, especially to get started and definitely for
debugging.
And that was it. So that's how I
wanted to tee up things, and I think
now we can get into some of the
new
Yes. I think I just lost your audio,
though.
Is
it working?
Oh, it works when I bring your screen
back.
Oh, okay. So There's a fun bug. Alright.
Let's try. How
about how about now?
Yeah. I have to keep bringing it I'm
gonna click the x on it and see
what happens.
And if I can't hear you, you might
just have to share it again. Let's let's
see let's see what happens.
Say hello.
Hello there. Alright. Okay. We're we're live.
Well,
wouldn't be a livestream without the hookup. That's
That's amazing. Hello.
I mean, I I've gotta say,
They said they took it to be true.
Well, let's see. Let's see how far we
can get with it to to to figure
out that story. I think the the big
part is getting the config right. And then
from there, it really does work like magic.
Those are some
I mean, the amount of functionality being packed
into what Skaffold I mean, to be completely
transparent, I haven't looked at Skaffold in probably
two years, at least eighteen months, but probably
more than two years. And I I it
just it's always added a lot of really
great features. And I've been able to slice
and dice, you know, all those different components
and the actions to break down to fit
the workflow that, you know, my teams, my
orgs, whatever wanna adopt.
Just seems great. So I'm really I'm really
excited there. Definitely really excited there. But I
think we should get my screen shared and
we should
start kicking the tires on this a little
bit. Cool.
Alright. So for anyone who wants to follow
along at home in their own time, you
have Skaffold.dev,
which is the documentation and the examples that
we we working from today
have gone ahead and cloned the Skaffold repository
because
they have a whole bunch of examples here
that we can kick our tires on and
play with today. And I don't see this
a lot. I cover a lot of open
source projects and it's really refreshing to see
a directory
full of examples tailored to different workloads and
different languages and stuff like that. So really
excited to see that as well.
Now if we just click on the docs,
I do have Skaffold installed. I spared you
all the the brew command to see how
to do that. Alright.
So
now should we start with quick start? Is
there anything here we should just kind of
do the really basic one before we start
picking a few examples? Yeah. I think this
this goes into the example. So you're kind
of streamlining that part already. I think if
you go into examples
and and check out the, yeah, the microservices
example is probably a nice representative one.
And I think, yeah, just c d into
microservices folder there. That's one we can check
out.
Awesome.
Alright. So should I just pop this open
in code, or are we just gonna work
directly in the command line? You can do
either. So I I would just do a
Skaffold dev here. And maybe, you know, before
we do that, can look at the Skaffold
YAML just to see what's in there because
I think the configs are nice to look
at.
Sweet.
So we'll just kinda go block by block
here. So you have your build section, which
is saying, what images do I wanna build?
And we call them artifacts.
Today, we're very focused around container images. So
we have two images that that we're building
in this app, but it's actually using a
third image as a base. Right? So you
have Leroy web and the Leroy app that
you supposed to see require the base image.
So here,
what Skaffold's gonna do is it's gonna first
build the base image and then build those
two other images after that point. So you
can kinda share a a base. Right? You
may have a GoLang app that uses the
same Go version or that you wanna keep
in sync somehow or you have some pattern
for, you know, dealing with your,
you know, authentication or logging or whatever, you
can put that into the base and then
use it from your two
application containers.
Then from that section, after that section, you
have the deploy section, which is gonna just
use raw Kubernetes manifest. You can see there
deploy, kube control manifest.
So it's gonna deploy, manifest with kube control,
and those are stored in those directories, and
we use a blob to describe
where those are.
And then the last section, I think, is
is really cool, and this is something we
recently changed. When you put this port forward
section in, you can describe what resources you
want to be port forwarded and what ports
you want them to be on. And then
Skaffold will automatically port forward these when you
run Skaffold dev. So then after the app
comes up, David, you'll be able to see
on Port 8080 the web app of this
application.
Alright. I think that all seems pretty familiar,
you know, like, maybe to like other tools,
you know, it doesn't look like Docker Compose,
I'm defining containers that I wanna run. I'm
seeing how to deploy them and I've got
my ports. So it's kinda there's this familiarity
to it at least. Absolutely. I quite like
that.
So what you're saying is if I just
run this magical Skaffold dev command, it's gonna
spin up these images, expose the port locally,
and I should
be able to browse to what port 9,000
and see our web app.
That's right.
So
alias on the I'm gonna assume this may
take just a few moments. So while that
does that Sure. We've got requires here for
the artifact that's requiring a container image. What
what's the alias of base? Why are we?
Yeah. I I don't think I understand what
this means.
Yeah. So if you can actually maybe pop
open in a in another window the
the Docker files, you'll see that we're passing
an argument
into
the the Docker build process.
Yep.
So you wanna take So then in base
yeah. It they base
a Dockerfile,
and that should be relatively
simple. Right? It's coming from distroless.
We're setting a environment variable there, and then
we're saying what command to run. So that's
kind of our basic config. And then if
you go into, like, Leroy app or Leroy
web, you'll see that we're using that alias
that we defined previously. So you see arg
base?
That's what lines us up there, and then
you'll see from base in the bottom. So
the arg kind of passes from the Skaffold
YAML
into the Dockerfile and then becomes a from
block in that Dockerfile that that's kind of
the leaf node there.
Right. Okay. Yeah. That makes sense. I think
I understand that now.
So it now seems to have built our
images.
And
by waiting for deployments to stabilize, I'm assuming
is that just waiting for the pods to
spin up, probes to maybe start passing, and
I think that. I do that correct.
Alright. Moment of truth. Is this working? Alright.
Of course, it is. There we go. There
it is. I mean, it's easy to get
text to render in a browser, but it's
hard to deploy that text into the programs
cluster sometimes.
Cool. That was
nice and simple.
Yeah. So now you should be able to
update
the text of that app and have it
rerun the loop relatively
quickly on your behalf.
Alright. So this is a Go application
that is just doing a format print. So
you're saying I should be able to add
Rawkode
says hello.
Yep. And just save
and then go back.
Cool. So it's picked up that change,
and now it's gonna redeploy or rebuild the
the Go app in this case and redeploy
it.
Okay. And that's just using
Docker under the hood right now because we
haven't really told us to do anything otherwise.
I'm I'm I'm able to take advantage of
layer caching and all that other goodness based
on how I configure my Docker file.
Yeah. And actually running Skaffold dev is how
I've
optimized my images over time because you start
to kinda watch it pretty intently, making sure
that your layers are right. And when you
change a certain file, and it doesn't do,
you know, weird things, so you can kinda
segment
the the the the files in your repo
a bit better. But what we do in
Skaffold is actually look at the Docker file
to find out which files are important to
watch.
Right? So if you're doing, for example, a
copy dot dot, so copying the entire source
tree into your doc file, yeah, the whole
source tree is gonna be active. So anytime
you change anything there, you're we're gonna rebuild.
But if you have very specific things, like
maybe only copying the Go files or your
Go binary things,
it will only update when you change those.
Alright.
Well, I'm definitely impressed with our first little
demo there. It's nice to see that working
end to end. I can see how that
development workflow is really
you know, we're I guess what every developer
wants is that really fast feedback loop from
when I change my code to when I
see the results or what I want. And
That's right. Skaffold is automated in that entire
step from saving the files to building the
image, pushing it to Kubernetes, deploying it to
Kubernetes, and then port forwarding it to me.
That's right. That's what I wanna see. I
like it thick. So
should we jump into another example?
Yeah. Sure. So we can
try maybe a file sync example.
So let's take a look.
I do have a question there. Just something
caught my eye. I control c that, and
it's also got a signal handler on it.
And it seems to have deleted those deployments
as well. That was pretty nice. That's right.
Yeah. So it'll clean up by default, and
then you can also have a flag dash
dash cleanup false if you wanna leave things
around. And that's usually for folks that have
something that takes a while to boot up,
and and they wanna make sure that they
have a running version in there to get
back to where they were.
Yeah. Cool.
Yeah. I was I I thought there when
I control c that I was like, oh,
that's probably not the best way to do
that, and I'm gonna have to clean it
up, but
it surprised me. Yeah. We'll handle those pieces
for you.
Alright. So that was a compiled Go application.
Can we take a look at something that's
interpreted in a bit more dynamic,
or do you wanna jump into something else
first? What what you think? Let's try the
you like TypeScript? Should we try a TypeScript
example? I actually haven't run this, so we
might as well,
you know, ask the demo gods to to
bless us with the TypeScript payment. Alright. Well,
I will repeat the same process, and I'll
run Skaffold dev first, jump jump over to
the other tab. We can take a look
at the Skaffold. Yml. That makes sense? Beautiful,
that's good.
Alright, so we can jump out of this.
Yeah, test script, there we go.
But I suspect this is probably gonna be
very similar until I say that. And of
course, we've got some profiles thing going on
here. So I'm gonna shut up and let
you just take that away. Let's see. So
in here, we have a few things that
are gonna be different. Right? The the image
part, the the artifacts
is very basic. Right? You define what the
image name is gonna be and then the
context
of where that image's Dockerfile is, for example.
In the profile section
is where we define kind of a different
SKU or a different way that we want
Skaffold
to operate depending on the commands you pass
to it. So here, this team, if we
wanna imagine it that way, has a development
profile. And so when we run Skaffold dev,
we're gonna pass
dash p for profile dev, which is the
name of this. Right?
And that allows you to run this particular
dev profile.
But you can also see that we have
an activation there that says anytime we're running
to the Skaffold dev command,
that it's gonna use this pro profile by
default. Right? So this is another way to
kind of catalog
the procedures
or the the the
workflow of your team.
And then the the real change here that
we have is that we're building the artifacts
with Docker, but we're also gonna sync
files to the container.
Right? So in some cases, with interpreted languages,
you're gonna wanna make sure that you don't
have to rebuild from scratch every time because,
really, what you wanna do is just shuttle
your files from your local file system out
into the running container and, you know, restart
your your running process. And so that's what
this is gonna do here. Right? And so
you can see, you can define the specific
files that you wanna be synced over. So
here, we have a manual sync, which means
don't try to infer what my syncing strategy
should be.
Sync these files, source the full glob, anything
TypeScript
into the destination,
which is the source folder on that side.
And so we should see very fast updates
here with no rebuild like we did in
in the Golang example and no compile, for
example.
Cool.
So the sync that's happening, I mean,
is that just running our sync into the
into the pod, or is it the, like
Not not quite our sync. Even even more,
I think, rudimentary than that. We're just tarring
things up and then copying them over to
the container and exploding them over there. So
we have the keep control copy command is,
I think, is being used under the hood
or maybe that was how it was done
previously and now we've done something fancier, but
it's a pretty basic implementation there. Yes. So
you're not actually modifying the container image that
I use from application in any way. You're
doing this purely over the APIs exposed through
Docker or Kubernetes, etcetera. That's right. Okay. That's
right.
Alright. So this is now
running.
How did we expose that?
Well, we don't have any port thing here.
So by default, it should expose the port
that is running there, but we might have
to if you go up, did it any
green lines of the port forwarding info show
up?
Looks like not. So we'll have to do
the dash dash port forward flag because no
port forwards were defined in the config file.
So this is just a way when doing
Skaffold dev to expose a port without modifying
the Skaffold configuration?
That's right. So let's just do, yeah, cleanup
and then dash dash port forward.
Let's see. It should auto detect. It should
just be the port forward flag with no
arguments, and it should be auto detected in
there.
Should is my favorite word on this show.
Oh, yeah. I you know, like I said,
I haven't done this this one before, so
we're gonna figure it out.
So we got a question, I guess, we
could tackle just now. Is asking, can Skaffold
be used for GitOps
environments?
Yeah. Definitely. So one of the things we
try to do is kinda chunk up the
pipeline that we have for Skaffold dev and
let you do individual pieces. Right?
And so
what you can do with, for example, the
Skaffold render command is all of the steps
that we showed except for the deployment piece.
And rather than deploying hey,
Instead of deploying,
you're going to get a YAML file that
has all of the things that you needed
in that file or all the things from
your configuration in that file. And so you
can put that into your Git repository, and
then that will be synced with whatever git
GitOps tool you're using.
Okay. Cool. Thank you. I think a few
members of the team are also jumping into
the comments and answering questions. So, yeah, thank
you to Jal and Nick. Okay.
So
this is exposing port 3,000 locally on 3,001,
I think. That's right.
We're gonna get a lot of hello world
web pages, I think, today. There it is.
That's about as far as I take my
side projects anyway, so I'm quite familiar with
this page.
But you gotta buy the domain first, obviously.
Oh, we oh, don't give me a start.
I
don't know why I feel so compelled to
buy domains for all every great idea that
I have only for them to set zero.
And then I renew them four times, and
then I go, maybe I'm done. Then maybe
I'm late.
No. You keep it. You keep it.
So
that's a hello world,
we're gonna make a modification to this application
then. So let's see. We got our
back end
source
index.
There we go.
Cool.
I'm just gonna save this.
Change is happening.
Re exposed.
So I guess with like a node JS
or a type script project, they have a
concept of like hot module reloading themselves. Is
that something I'm gonna be able to get
to work or would I
quit running yet? Yeah. So you should so
your app is gonna need to do whatever
it needs to do to be able to
detect the change. Right? So for example, like,
I've I've used Django in the past, and
you have to pass a particular flag to
it to, know, actually reload itself.
And so that would have to be set
in your application.
What Skaffold is gonna do, its part in
this is getting the files over to the
new container or the the built container.
Yeah. I guess just because this is looking
at the code now, this is just a
really simple express express application to show how
that interpreted thing works with the sync. So
this that's probably not gonna have hot module
real. But I can imagine if I were
to use Next. Js or one of these
other fancy frameworks that may
just work out of the box. I'm gonna
leave that as an experiment for another day,
but something I'm curious to try in my
own project.
So that's pretty cool.
Yeah. I wanted to show something
from these examples
and how the images
are placed into the configurations.
So if we go back to the Skaffold
YAML, and we see that we define the
images and their names,
we didn't really give a fully qualified name
here. So if you look at build artifacts
on that first image, it's called node TypeScript
example.
That name
has to match what's in your Kubernetes manifest.
Right? So that's how we know the thing
that we built is the thing that needs
to go into your Kubernetes manifest.
So if you go back into that Kate's
folder, you should see a deployment that has
that specific image name in there. And that's
not something that necessarily is, you know, for
example, on Docker Hub, which is where, you
know, Docker would look first.
So we make sure that we replace that
with the one that's locally built. And since
you're using Docker desktop, which has the Docker
daemon shared between Kubernetes and Docker, the image
is built locally and then runs straight off
of that Docker cache. Right? And that's how
we get some speed improvements there.
But you could also,
for example, use a flag on the Skaffold
build command or Skaffold deployer, any of those
that says, tack on a prefix to this.
Right? Where the prefix might be, you know,
gcr. I o slash
vix.
Right? And then that'll tack on that so
that it goes to my private registry when
it builds. Right? So we have that flexibility
to be able to do things kind of
in a streamlined way in in development and
then point it at a more production style
approach
via flags and config.
Alright. Cool. Yeah. I was actually curious about
the the image stuff, so it's nice to
get that kind of clarified. We just understand
how that actually works and what's expected from
that. We kind of end user there too.
Yeah.
Alright. So I'm gonna let Skaffold clean that
up. We'll jump back into examples.
This is the normal LS.
So we've taken a look at compiles with
Go. We're taking a look at Terpitude with
TypeScript.
Let's see what catches our eye. Build packs
build packs example. I don't know how many
folks have used build packs in the past,
but build packs is a really easy way
to get kinda streamlined image builds without having
a Dockerfile.
And Skaffold is a really easy way to
get going with build packs, and we'll see
that in the Skaffold channel for that one.
So is this cloud native build packs or
the classic kinda Heroku
build pack? This this is the cloud native
build pack. Specifically, the GCP build packs, I
think, are what's configured in this, but we
support any of the packers that are available.
So if you look at that Skaffold YAML,
it should have
the,
yeah, the builder config in there. So you
see our image
has another block under it that says build
packs. By default, we're gonna look for a
Docker file,
but you can configure
Skaffold to grab
create images in various ways. Right? It could
be did a session with you on Cameco.
Right? You wanna run-in cluster with a Docker
list
build. You can do that. This is another
approach which uses build packs, which actually pack
your image from source code directly. So you
don't even have to have a Dockerfile to
tell it how to build your image. It
just detects, hey. You have a Python app.
Python apps generally have a requirements dot TXT.
I'm gonna get your dependencies in place with
that, and then I'm gonna go ahead and
build that image for you and push it
to the registry.
And so the way you define how you
want those images to be built or what
standard of of building you want is via
that builder configuration there.
So does this mean when I run a
Skaffold dev, we're gonna see something slightly different
from what we're seeing in the presentation? Yeah.
Specifically
in the image build, you'll see a lot
more happening
than your usual Docker files. Let's take a
look at that.
Let's see. So
it's pulling the builder image.
So this builder image contains all of the
code that understands how to go from source
code to a built image
in the OCI context. I'm assuming for multiple
languages, giving the number of layers and the
size of it is that it's probably like
a It is ubiquitous super It's a bit
chunky.
Yeah. So, yeah, this will have all of
the things you need, and it's that builder
v one
that we have in the the Skaffold YAML,
and it'll be for Java, Python, Node, all
those languages, all the same. So you only
really have to pay this, quote, unquote, tax
one time, and then you should be good.
Alright. Doesn't seem too bad. Yes. Sorry to
go. Quickly.
And so this will be kind of the
initialization
in a lot of cases with, you know,
these dev loops and containers is getting the
right bits into the right places. And then
from there, we do fun tricks with layering
and a bunch of other stuff to make
things fast from that point. Cool. So we
just pulled the builder image, and now it's
actually gonna look for the run image. So
how do I run this image, which may
not be the same way that I build
this image. Right? It's just how we do
kind of distroless images for security purposes and
things like that. It'll actually build a really
lean image when it runs, but have some
more
content in there for for when it builds.
Okay. So you saw at the top there
it's detecting? Yep.
Yeah. I was just gonna say it's
to try to detect what kind of code
we have inside of here, it has correctly
identified that we have Python.
It seems to bring in that there's maybe
some sort of pep file, not looking at
the code, but that would make sense. I'm
not sure what the analyzer
is doing with this, but then it just
starts to build.
I guess that's good.
So then I don't even need to write
a Dockerfile. I can just leverage build packs,
and it'll
do the right thing, hopefully.
That's right. And, like, it's not the hardest
thing in the world to get, you know,
Docker files written, but to get a good
one that's lean, that has the right dependencies,
and that works cross language
is definitely harder.
So this can help you kinda standardize things
down and have one less thing to worry
about in your ecosystem.
Well, yeah. I mean, it's one of those
things that, you know, if you can draw
an experience of an entire community that are
focused on maintaining these build packs to produce
production images for runtimes and languages, like Exactly.
Who who wouldn't want to take advantage of
that, really?
And build packs are something that I I
think are really cool. I just I've always
thought it was maybe just too early from
what I've seen, but maybe that's changed. Maybe
it's maybe it's getting better.
I think one of the challenges is just
getting build packs. Right? Like, how do you
run them? You have to have a CLI.
In this case, Skaffold is running all of
those pieces for you. So it's just adding
that little config block that you saw, and
then Skaffold takes care of the rest for
you, which I think is is a ease
of use improvement that that build packs
needed a nudge towards. But they have their
own CLI if you wanna run this, for
example, in CI or whatever.
Okay. So I have noticed that this one
has, you know, taken a little bit longer
than the first two examples. Is this something
that is gonna be a lot quicker as
I make changes to the application? Like, we're
not gonna have to watch all of that
again. Right?
Right. So you you'll have actually in we
have an integration with Buildpacks to do syncing
as well.
And so you'll get some optimizations again through
how Skaffold does all these underlying tools
to
automatically sync the right things over to that
container
when necessary.
And maybe we can get someone to post
the the link to those docs. If not,
I can find them real quick.
Alright. Well, it looks like we have our
Python application running, but I don't think I've
seen the port forward.
Maybe that we need to add that.
Yeah. The dash dash port forward command might
be necessary on there. Alright. So let's just
try that again.
And then we'll see
what happens with the speed here.
Yeah. It's it's just been straight to deploy.
But I guess that makes sense. Nothing has
actually changed in the the application. Right.
So, yeah, eighty eighty one. Cool.
What is the hello world message? Oh, lowercase
hello world with a comma. I like it.
Mixing up. Yeah. Definitely.
Alright. Okay. So we got web dot py.
Hello, world.
Let's just standardize
this. Let's save.
And that's now going through the build pack
stage again.
And so it's reusing a bunch of the
things that it already did in the past
here.
Don't think in this case, it's actually syncing.
Yeah.
I was gonna say, I don't think I
see anything here to suggest that it was
maybe just syncing the fails into the
running container.
Yeah. It looks like it's rebuilding in this
case, and we may need to actually
set something in that example to get it
to auto sync.
Oh, you know what it is? I think
it's only for Go, Java, and Node. Js.
So have we picked a different language? Maybe.
Yeah.
That's it. Right? Blame me. That's fine. Whatever.
I think I think I was the one
who chose the Python. So Yeah. I think
you said build pack, and I was like,
oh, let's do Python. But yeah. Okay. We
could try another one as well. I guess,
if anything can make Java fast, that's definitely
a one in many people's books because that's
almost a point of a point of frustration
for people developing against Kubernetes. At least the
people I speak to, it's always a pun
of frustration.
There we go. Yeah. And we actually have
a a Java specific builder as well called
Jib. So if you look in those examples,
you'll see another very similar approach to to
building images that are that are lean and
and fast
is the the Jib
examples in there, but that's specific only to
Java.
So if you go to, for example,
Jib,
just the regular Jib example,
this should
let's see. Oh, you might need to have
Maven installed for this one.
Why would I need Maven installed?
Because Jim actually uses Maven
under the hood. Well, it is a part
of the Maven build process.
So it gets involved with your actual Java
project
and
builds the image in a very
efficient way for Java applications and then can
update that image in a very efficient way.
And so you see, we the way we
define that here in the artifact section rather
than having build packs under the image like
we did last time to tell it we're
not using a Docker file. It's actually using
JIT there.
Okay. Well, I don't believe I have Maven,
so maybe we should
move on to We can go on to
a a different one,
and maybe we'll just do
maybe multi config
microservices.
I know Thomas has been waiting for this
one to show up. Maybe more as well.
Let's see.
Cool.
Okay.
So it looks very similar to the last
microservices.
So I'm expecting we're gonna be to see
something different in the Skaffold.
Let's check it out. Oh, look at that.
A little bit different. Little bit less context
at the root folder here
about what's going on in the repo. What
we're doing here is using a feature that
we call modules or config dependencies.
Right? And so this allows you to take
a kind of broken up app, which maybe
it has Helm charts plus Kubernetes manifest in
the back end and the front end or,
in this case, the app and the web,
and create individual
Skaffold YAMLs for each of those and then
reference them from a a common
Skaffold or
root Skaffold.
So this way,
I can have dependencies on other services that
live maybe in my repo or maybe outside
of my repo. And this requires block lets
me pull those in into my local development
environment. So you can imagine you depend on
a back end service that, you know, your
team doesn't really own. You can point at
their repo
and pull in their latest, you know, stable
build
so so that you can develop your app
against their app at the same time.
Great. Okay. That makes sense. So I could
have
I I'm trying to say, guys, it's up
to work, like, in practice. So if I've
got many teams teams all built on their
own microservices and their own repositories with their
own Skaffold configurations,
I could have, like, an app of apps
repository that would allow me to spin up
everything
by reaching out to all of those other
repositories.
That's right. And so here, we're we're using
the path
way to configure this, but it could also
be pointing to a Git repo, right, and
a and a specific branch within that Git
repo or a specific folder and branch within
that Git repo. And it's not just for
the app of apps
kind of pattern. It could be just to
have your particular slice
of dependent services. Right? So you might have,
you know, a front end service that requires
x, y, and z back end. You don't
really want the whole universe to be built.
You just need the three other services or
the two other services that you require. And
so you can kinda just get that little
DAG built out in your your
local environment.
Okay. So I I I've got one more
question. I don't know if you just answered
it, but I'm gonna just ask it anyway
to see if it changes anything that
maybe just doesn't click into my head. So
if I just want to
so
I've got a
I've got an application that's got three services.
I'm working on one service, but I need
the other
two.
And I wanna use the app of apps
or best kind of config where I have
the required on the three services. Like, can
I say that I want to launch all
of them in like a
not not production, but almost production manner, and
then one of them in, like, a dev
profile where I can do the iteration on
it? Is that all possible? Right. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. So you can start to kind of
tick on and off flavors of the various
apps and and pieces that you want. But
if you look at kind of the the
Leroy app and the Leroy app, Skaffold YAMLs,
they'll just look like normal Skaffold YAMLs. And
what when you require one of these, we
pull in the config and kind of mash
it together so that you get the right
order of events. Right? All the images are
built together, then all of the deployments happen
together, for example. And so it's a really
nice way to kind of break up this
microservices
dependencies
and let you have a unified way to
to develop between
services.
And is it possible to not do the
build and only leverage, like, the actual deploy
aspect of some of the apps, but then
do the build for one specific? Yes. Yeah.
Nodding. I'm happy. Yeah.
No. That that and I think that's probably
the pattern that that we want the most
is, you know, if you do have dependent
services, you don't really wanna depend on their
repo,
probably. You wanna depend on some, you know,
stamped out version, a stable set of manifests.
Yeah. Right? So you could have a module
that only has a deployed block in there
and just pull in those static manifests because,
really, you want a working version.
Right? In some cases, though, you might wanna
actually develop on both. And so you can
do both of those patterns,
whether it's, like, static manifest that pull in
the stable or the upstream kind of trunk
version of their app, including their source code.
Okay. I like the scent of all of
this. So I am just gonna go and
run our Skaffold dev. And I expect this
is gonna be super uneventful,
same as all the other examples and just
work, and I'm not gonna have any good
questions for you.
But I like it when things just work.
It's a it's a nice change from my
actual day job where nothing I do works.
Don't worry. It's taken a lot of effort
from a lot of folks who are are
in the chat here to make sure these
these samples work, and I think they're they're
a great example of kind of the the
breadth of functionality we have.
One of the things we're definitely gonna be
focusing on in the back half of the
year is how to put it all together.
You'll see, like, a lot of our examples
are very pointed towards specific features. So we'll
start getting some more complex examples that show
a bunch of different pieces
being stacked together.
Cool. So that looks like it's, well, it's
just worked.
We got our services exposed on port 18001.
I'm gonna hit 9000
and assume I'm gonna get a hello world.
Oh, the Leroy app. Okay. There we go.
Alright.
Yeah. I think
it's definitely starting to make a lot of
sense now of how I would want to
structure this. I I just think that require
with the path and the repository based way
is where I naturally wanna start taking my
applications. Because I think it's how
you know, I I don't really want, like,
a monolithic configuration for everything to run my
thing in production. I really want each team
to have the autonomy to say how to
develop and run their app.
One thing we might wanna check out while
we're here is the Skaffold, like, the individual
commands. Right? So we've seen kind of the
the loop, and people have been asking about
DevOps or CI or how this fits in.
So if you cancel out of here, we
can do the Skaffold build, and you'll see
what that does,
which as you can imagine,
all it does is it's gonna build. Right?
Just do the build, and we can tell
it to output the artifacts. So if we
do Skaffold build dash dash
file output
and then artifacts dot JSON or whatever,
it's a file dash output, actually. Yeah. I
I thought it was gonna be that, but
then changed my mind. Okay. Art of dot
JSON?
Yep.
Cool.
We already have the images built, so it's
no no extra magic there. We're just using
the caching. And then it let's take a
look at that file and see what information
is in there. You might wanna do it
with JQ or Beth.
I guess.
I think you can just do j q,
can't you? Yeah. I think so.
Oh, I need a dash f for something.
Yeah. Let's do it the way you there
we go. Alright.
And so not nothing special in here, but
just to show that, you know, we have
the images named. We have the specific tag
that we built,
and then we can pass this into other
places we might need it. Right? So you
can imagine your CI process when you've committed
to main,
you know, runs this and then creates this
artifacts. JSON is saying, here is the latest
images
from this particular commit. Then you might wanna
pass that into your CD process. Right? And
so here, we can do Skaffold render
and then pass it in that file.
We might need to do help because I
don't remember the exact
I think it is the build artifacts
flag or dash a
that will pass in the file. So this
is saying, hey. I have a bunch of
Kubernetes config that I want you to, you
know, put these images into. And so we'll
pass it that file,
and it should spit out a bunch of
YAML.
Great.
So now we can see in the specs
for the deployments,
it's taken those image names that were kind
of the basic name, Leroy web, Leroy app,
and put in the fully qualified tag there.
So then we can go right back to
exactly that image that was built.
And so you might wanna, for example, put
this into a file and then run Skaffold
apply against it, and Skaffold apply will apply
it into the cluster.
I probably shouldn't do that.
Oh, yeah. But
there you go.
So let's see.
Apply.
We can do dash f
just like It is just
the
file name as a positional argument.
That that'll be the the Skaffold commit. Yeah.
So, again,
very, you know, simple. Right? But you get
to take the same configuration file that you've
defined all of these reusable
parameters for. Right? These things don't change that
much, and then apply them at different stages
throughout your process. And so that's a very,
you know, powerful thing that you can kind
of bidirectionally
influence
folks. Right? The developers can opt you know,
influence how the deploys are gonna work, and
the operators can influence how the development might
work. Right? And so that's something that we
haven't really had in the past
to as as kind of a a key
feature in these tools. Mhmm.
Okay. So
you mentioned something earlier during your slides is
that, you know, Skaffold gives me the ability
to kind of hook into other tools. Like
you said, for the build layer, I can
use, you know, Canico or I can use
Docker or something else. What about for the
render layer? Does it have the ability to
hook into to customize or helm or other
things? Like, I can imagine
if I want to develop my application, it
may have a requirement maybe on some helm
charts or something like that. Yeah.
So we do support that. So if you
go to the examples, we support both Helm
and Customize today. We also have alpha support
for kept in there if folks are are
looking at that tool. But, essentially, yeah, we're
we're looking to kind of abstract the idea
of manifest management so that you can run
something like Skaffold Render. And, you know, you
can imagine as you kinda put this into
the CICD
pipeline,
you can have a very standardized CICD pipeline
where the teams themselves are using a bunch
of different tools. And as an operator, you
might not have to care whether they're using
Helm or customize or anything else. You're abstracted
away from that. So if we go on,
like, for example, the Helm deployment repo,
we can see an example of Helm.
Okay. So Helm
deployment sounds like I might be deploying my
application with Helm. I like like the sense
of dependencies because it makes me think that
I'm using something else for my app and
Helm for a dependency.
That's it. All right, okay.
So I'm gonna take a look at Skaffold.
It's a bit bigger.
Yeah. We got some sort of helm
release.
And so here, you can really just kind
of define it. Know, essentially, we're extracting just
how you run Helm. Right? So you can
see a lot of the flags that you
would pass to Helm are now inside of
our Skaffold YAML, and we're kind of putting
those as as code. Right? You have, you
know, skip build dependencies. You have
artifact overrides.
You have set values at the bottom. So
it's really a way to kinda catalog the
procedure
of how you use the tool underneath the
hood. We have very similar pattern for customized.
You'll see a customized flags and and things
like that.
Yeah. I think the dependency thing there was
a little bit different as expecting, but it
was still useful to see what we could
on there.
And they So you're kinda looking at, like,
I have a Redis chart or something like
that that I depend on. How would I
bring that in? Yeah. You know, I'm working
on some sort of roster, Alexa application. It
has Redis post grads as backing stores for
cache and stateful stuff. Like, I still wanna
be able to run those services, but I
wouldn't necessarily have,
you know, a build step or anything like
that to to orchestrate that.
Yeah. So in that case, think what what
you would want is, like, chart path to
actually be a URL. Right? And so then
you can point at a chart somewhere else
in the tarball for that chart, and we'll
put it in. In this case, it's just
the path on the local file system, but
it should work with remote dependencies as well.
Yeah. And I guess to this deploy block,
I'm just adding my own application stuff as
well as that helm dependency for the charter
that need. So Exactly. Exactly.
And part of our, you know, effort over
the next, you know, couple months is to
make that separation a lot cleaner and make
sure that you can combine a bunch of
different tools. Right? You can imagine on your
side, you're building with your config with customized,
but you depend on something from Helm. Right?
And so we wanna be able to have
both of those be living in harmony. Right
now, it's a little clunkier than we'd like.
Yeah. Even the customized example is nice and
simple. I I just they wanna deploy with
customize, and then it just uses my straight
up customization dot YAML. So That's it. Yeah.
Same defaults where we where we can have
them. That's sure.
Alright. Nice. I I like how all the
bits are kinda joining together.
And the just so far, the configuration has
been pretty simple, which I like.
Though
as we were kinda talking and looking at
this direction, the React reload one caught my
eye, and I think that's exactly what I
was talking about earlier. So if I mean,
if we're feeling brave, I really wanna jump
in there and see if that does what
it says it does. Let's
test our bravery here. What are we gonna
jump into? I've never run this example, so
it'll be a surprise for me too. Oh,
again, that disclaimer end early. Nice. Alright.
So, yeah, it's got a sync, which is
exactly what I wanted. So really what I
wanna see here, and I'm hoping this does
what I what I expect, is that when
I run Skaffold dev,
let that build, we'll have deployable browser application.
And I'm gonna just move my terminal over
to the browser, but I expect that when
I save the file and let's get that
ready to
so we add real
we add reload
App index, not source.
That's the change of React bit.
Man.
Nope. Components.
Right. There we go.
We should be able to change this and
I'm curious if we will get that.
Like the browser is gonna detect that something
changed and do the reload for me. That
would be really cool.
Let's see.
That happens, I'm buying you a beer.
I'll
take it. Take as many as I can
get.
We'll we'll do an IOU for that one.
Yeah. Yeah. Definitely. Keep going early maybe.
Sounds great.
So
NPM install, I mean, no tool in the
world can speed that up. But I I
think it's Sorry. Yeah. We we haven't gone
to tackle that yet. Maybe maybe if we
get enough issues, we'll see what we can
do about NPM install.
Alright. We're almost there. So
let's just pop this over.
And we'll port.
Oh, it's not there yet. Almost.
K. So it's compiled.
Did we do the port forward command on
this one or no?
Or flag.
Yeah. From now on, every Skaffold dot YAML
I work with is gonna have the the
port forward stuff in it. Yes. That is
that is one of the things we've now
started recommending it as a as a best
practice. We should probably go put that into
the
examples here too. There we go. Eighty eighty
one.
That's good.
That's the most beautiful hello world we've put
together today, I will say.
It has color for once. Right. So I've
changed it, but I've not saved it. So
it
worked.
I did not touch my browser.
That was awesome.
Very nice. Good choice of example.
Let's just
for the sake of maybe changing the CSS,
I I only know, like, three color codes.
So we're just gonna
do that
and
save.
What
we wanna see. That's really nice.
So let's see what actually Skaffold was doing
there.
Now because it's the sync, I'm assuming it's
really just
the NPM tool chain. Yeah.
And Skaffold, other than checking the files into
the container, you're just relying on all those
native tools to do their job. Right?
That's it.
That's it. We we do the the most
basic thing we can, and a lot of
the tools like like this one have that
piece figured out.
Alright. Well,
Thomas Stromberg
had fingers crossed and sadly,
Dan is also a witness to the free
beer. Yeah. Yeah. Dan, you can have a
beer too, whatever. Alright. Thank you.
We got one slash comment slash question from
Aiger. I thought Skaffold is for building containers.
No, that is Canico. We had an episode
on that last week. You should check that
out. It was also a very very cool
tool.
And I guess Skaffold, I could just set
the builder to Canico and have that do
the thing there too, which would be That's
right. Pretty nice. Yeah. And we try to
do, like you said, you know, try as
little config as possible based on how those
tools work to to make it work. So,
hopefully, it makes it easy to get with
Buildpacks, Canico, any other builder that you can
think of.
Cool. Awesome. Well,
we're kind of approaching our now. Is there
anything
from the examples that you wanna show before
we move on to, like, the
I I can. We can do the the
test one, but I can also show a
little bit more complicated example. I think we've
shown
a lot of the different features, and I
have just one kind of mega example that
I can walk through with various pieces
stitched together.
Yes. But you want to show show us
the test one then and then switch over?
Yeah. That's good. Yeah. Is is that the
structure test or something else? Custom test is
the the one we recently added.
So one of the things we didn't really
have in in Skaffold until recently is the
ability to, like, run your unit test as
part of that loop. And so that's what
this functionality
does. For each of the images that's built,
you can run a command
when that image gets done building.
In this case, they're gonna, you know, echo
hello world again,
run a test
script, and that's gonna run locally on your
machine. Right? So after the image build, you
might run a Docker image or you might
do Go test or something like that, for
example.
Right. Okay.
So it runs locally on my machine. It
doesn't run-in the container or anything like that.
Today. Yeah. Today, our the functionality is to
just be in kind of the the local
machine, but we're looking at what it might
be look like for running inside a cluster
or running somewhere else. If you have input
here, you know, please reach out.
Awesome. So you want me just to run
Skaffold dev as normal here or Skaffold test.
Right? Or Yeah. Skaffold test. So, actually, you
should be able to just do Skaffold dev,
and that should run the whole thing.
Alright. Let's see what happens.
The certain or a container image build.
What's in that test fail? Should we take
a look at that just now? Yeah, let's
try.
Oh, I thought my computer was up there.
It's just that tab.
Oh, no. I just
computers.
Oh, no. It's very unhappy. I think my
computer's Our demos have been going way too
well. I think something needs to go wrong
at this point. Yeah.
I struggle a little bit, but I think
it it'll cook. It'll be fine. Yes. This
is just running go test then.
Yeah. So just something basic, but, you know,
out of that all whole flow that I
was talking about, having to run anything out
of band kind of breaks up the model.
Right? So you wanna be able to loop
in as many of the things that you
need. Some other, you know, examples like I'll
show is maybe you wanna test your manifest,
right,
and doing something like conf task, for example.
So
is this the logs from my application? We
haven't seen that yet. Yeah. Yeah. So most
of the other things didn't log arbitrarily.
This one shows an example of the log
streaming back. So when I said, you know,
port forwarding and logging, right, you need to
both be able to reach your app, but
then also see what your app is doing.
So those are are both part of the
Skaffold dev loop, and you can also get
that to run on Skaffold deploy. Yeah. You
know what? I'm not sure why that caught
me off guard because we were looking at
the note logs, and we were looking at
the other logs. But for some reason, this
one just stuck out in my head. But,
yeah, we're getting the logs directly.
Yeah. It's hard to differentiate the build from
the server starting and not saying anything else.
So here, you can kinda see the live
streaming part of that.
Okay. Nice. Okay. So if built our image
is deploying it, it runs a test step
here. That worked successfully,
so it just
deployed it. If the test were to fail,
does that change the the workflow here? Does
it does it exit? Does it deploy the
older image?
What happens?
So it keeps the old image if it
fails. So it would show,
basically, a red text for for the failure,
and it won't deploy the new version. We're
gonna look at how we can make that
configurable and make it do different things if
things fail. But at the moment, it will
just stop. It won't stop the loop. The
loop will keep going. So if you fix
the test, then you can keep going, but
it won't redeploy.
Okay. Perfect.
Alright. That's all awesome.
I'm really excited by what I've seen. I
loved the little live reload. I'm I'm really
glad I caught that directory and we got
to see that work into the test stuff
is and
just all the different components and the ability
to slice and dice the commands to do
the each step that I need for my
worked really well. So why don't we hop
over to your screen now?
Cool.
You're gonna walk us through
something a bit more
feature complete complex. I'm not sure what word
to use, but I'll let you take it
away.
I think that both of those should apply.
So so, basically, what I'm gonna try to
do in in this example is is tie
it all together. I'm gonna close all my
my tabs so I can get oh, and
it's closed. One too many.
There's a cool Versus code plugin called macros,
and I've got, like, command l map to
close all the window tabs. I recommend it.
I
will do that after this, I guess. Let's
see.
So reopen here. Apologies for that.
So I've got
kinda just show the structure here of things.
So I've got this sample app. In this
case, I don't have tree installed.
In this case, it has two components.
One is the back end,
and that's gonna have its own Kubernetes manifest.
And
it's a Go app that is built with
a Docker file,
and then it also has a front end.
So very similar to our microservices example.
It also uses a base image. So then
I have, basically, my
user creation
in in my base image. I have command
to run within the app in my base
image, and then I leverage that in the
front end and back end. And the way
I'm tying that together
is with a root level Skaffold YAML, which
brings in three different modules. One is the
test module,
the other is the back end module, and
then the front end module. And the front
end module, as we'll see in its Skaffold
YAML,
depends on the back end
and the testing module
and the base image.
So let's go ahead and go into the
front end. Let's say I'm a front end
developer,
and I want to
run
my dev loop. I have
at the bottom here, you'll see my port
forward's already defined. So if I just run
Skaffold dev,
that should work. Let me just real quick.
Oops.
Let me get my Docker socket back.
Alright. So now I have my dev loop
right,
and you'll see in here that I'm doing
the test phase,
and that's gonna run a Docker image. Right?
So I get the image that was just
built, and I run a a script inside
of it. And what I'm gonna do with
that script
is this validate script is gonna build my
configuration
and then run contest against a set of
policies.
And those policies can be in your own
repo. They can be in a shared repo.
But it's things like, you know, the
containers not being able to run as root.
Right? So if someone were to change, for
example, the Docker file or change the app
in some way that required it to run
through,
they you would be able to block that
via the contest. So so here, I have
my application
running.
And let's say I wanted to you know,
I was slightly a nefarious developer, and I
wanted to run my app as as a
as root for some reason. I would go
and try to change this,
you know, run as non root to false.
And if I did that,
my dev loop would start again because it's
part of my application that I want, you
know, realized in my cluster,
and then it's gonna test. And I can
see here that it actually failed. Right? And
so I can now have this feedback
about my configuration
at the time that I'm developing. So then
I can change that back
and get back within, you know, the organizational
policies that constrain me. And now I can
develop again,
and it's deploying, and everything's back happy. Right?
So I just wanted to show kind of
the the whole end to end with modules
connecting to
the each other, right, from the front end
and back end, shared base module for an
image,
as well as the ability to have some
shared testing framework, like, for example, for your
Kubernetes manifest that you can use across multiple
repositories.
And that was basically it, unless there's any
other questions you have there. Nice. That was
awesome.
And let me get us back to.
There we go. Cool.
Well, I think that was quite successful. We
actually I thought I got broken this and
that's rare. I
I am, you know, I am counting my
lucky stars. I I think today's a lucky
day for me because I've never seen, like,
six or seven demos run pretty flawlessly. Maybe
it was the operator that really did it.
Yeah. Definitely. That's exactly what it was. Just
no. I'm really impressed. Like I said, it's
been a
long time since I've played with Skaffold and
it's really nice to just see how it's
bringing a really
almost like fluid,
almost intuitive developer experience to have us just
want things to work.
So really impressive stuff, and I'm looking forward
to seeing what's gonna come next with the
Skaffold project.
Awesome.
Thank you so much. And if folks wanna
engage, we have the Skaffold project on GitHub.
So please, you know, meet us there with
some issues or comments or questions. We're also
on Stack Overflow.
Alright.
Well, you heard it there. Check it out.
Play with it. If you have any problems,
reach out on GitHub, Stack Overflow, etcetera. People
will do their best to help you.
Vic, thank you for joining me today. Really
cool. Really happy with that. I will speak
to you again soon and have a great
day.
Awesome. Thanks, Dave. Bye.